We'd like the cross bar switching algorithm to achieve
what's called a maximal matching. Conceptually we have a router
with n inputs and n outputs, but of course the
inputs are also outputs. It's just easier to think about
the inputs and the outputs being separate when we
talk about the switching problem. Now in each time slot,
we would like to achieve a one-to-one mapping between inputs
and outputs, which is a matching. And our goal is
that the matching should be maximal. So in a
particular time slot, we might have a certain set
of traffic demands, or traffic at certain input ports,
that is destined for certain output ports. And our goal
is, given these demands, to produce a matching that
is maximal and fair. Now, given demands for a particular
time slot and the resulting matching, notice that certain
demands were not satisfied. These packets that arrived at inputs
must wait until the next time slot to be
forwarded to the appropriate output port, because they couldn't
be matched in the same time slot as those
shown here. Remember that there must be exactly a
one-to-one matching between any inputs and outputs in a
particular time slot. Most router crossbars have a notion
of speedup whereby multiple matchings can be performed in
the same time slot. So for example, if the line
cards are running at, say, ten gigabits per
second, then running the interconnect twice as fast
would allow matchings to occur twice as fast
as packets would arrive on the inputs or be
forwarded from the outputs. It is thus common
practice to run the interconnect at a higher
speed than the input and output ports. Just
speeding up the interconnect does not solve all problems.
Note, for example, that in this set of
demands we have packets arriving at this input
port destined for this output port, but if
there's only a single queue at this input,
the packets that are destined for the output
port, circled in orange, might actually be blocked
behind a set of packets that are destined for other output ports. So even if we
could induce a speed up at the interconnect, certain packets may be blocked
in the queue by packets ahead of them destined for other output ports.